minutes ago we spoke with White House
budget director Mick Mulvaney from the
White House morning charlie why do you
think an ultimatum will work now with
the caucus when it hasn't before because
I think you've got a new president in
place and a president who tried to
deliver the message last night which is
that the Republicans are all in the same
page
yesterday was the seventh anniversary of
the signing of Obamacare today should be
the beginning of its unwinding we're all
looking for the same things we want to
take Obamacare away and give people the
control and the options that they want
but the quality that they deserve and
the affordability that they need but we
need to start it and do it today
budget director this plan polls suggest
this plan is is is very unpopular at
this point 56% of Americans disapprove
of it
74 percent nearly three-quarters oppose
cutting Medicare funding yeah first of
all the nothing here cuts Medicare so
I'm not sure where that's coming from
but according me that's fine that's fine
I do that all the time I'm sure that
most folks don't know what's in the bill
we have made the bill much better over
the course of the last weeks of course
it has to go to the Senate after this my
guess is most people don't know the
phase two regulatory reforms or the
phase three additional bills the point
of the matter is this they know they
don't like Obamacare people back home no
they don't like it it takes the control
of their own health care out of their
hands it takes affordability away from
them and they want something better
what's sitting in the House today is
better than that and this is the chance
to pass it mr. Mulvaney when you talk
about something better does that include
the slashing of essential services
including maternity care emergency
services and prescription drugs sure and
I love the term slashing those essential
services keep in mind and I've talked to
many of my colleagues about this over
the last couple days states not only
have the ability to require those
services many of them already do I
talked to some folks from the Northeast
and they say yeah we don't really mind
that much about essential health
benefits because our states already
require insurance policies sold in those
states to have that what we're doing is
taking away the federal control of these
systems if you live in a state that
wants to mandate maternity cover
coverage for everybody including 60
year-old women that's fine want to live
in a state that wants to do different do
that
then you can figure out a way to change
the state that you live in why do we
look to the federal government to tell
no they could try to change their own
state legislatures and their state laws
why do we look to the federal government
to try and fix our local problems that's
one of the big problems with Obamacare
took that one-size-fits-all and crammed
it down on the entire country as a
result you have a system where everybody
just about can afford to have insurance
but nobody can actually afford to go to
the doctor and that's what we're trying
to fix and that's what the House bill
does there are many people who say it is
not only members of Congress who are at
risk here it is the president agenda
that if he cannot get through a
replacement healthcare that the rest of
his agenda will be at risk a couple of
different things on that first of all
the rest of the agenda will stand on its
own the tax policy will stand on its own
merits the infrastructure policy will
stand on its own marriage that merits
the other efforts to put people back to
work of which this is one by the way
there's excellent data from many sources
that show that Obamacare depresses the
the desire to go to work it takes an
incentive away from going to work so
this is actually a jobs bill today on
the house but in any event all of those
other policies will stand on their own
merit but folks will still have to be
accountable lawmakers will have to be
accountable so why they didn't vote to
get rid of Obamacare when they had the
chance and that chance is today Mick
Mulvaney thank you for joining us thanks
y'all